[Music]
if you would like to
you
okay welcome back everybody um so uh
hope you all had a nice break so we're
now going to continue uh our exposition
of quantum codes we are very lucky to
have Nico Brickman here from the
University of Bristol uh Nico is an
expert on Quantum ldbc codes and also
one of the co-organizers of the quantum
program so thank you for pulling double
duty and also giving us a talk um and
he'll tell us about Quantum ldpc codes
this is part one part two will be
tomorrow right right take it away thank
you so
much um yeah so actually I uh um I
didn't actually know exactly what the
definition of a boot cam was and um I
looked it up on M Webster and one of the
definitions was uh it's a program where
young offenders are forced to
participate and I really I really hope
that uh uh I can kind of get some
participation out of you um um even
though it's like quite quite quite late
um so um yeah I very much encourage you
to um ask questions and to um that makes
it more more fun for me and I hope also
more um take more okay um so John's talk
has only been 30 minutes uh uh ago but
um yeah as you may know inform de very
fast so let me kind of start off with
some
reminder and uh the
reminder what you've just
seen is the following so in John's talk
uh he kindly already introduced CSS
codes so CSS standing for k bank uh show
and steam
Quantum
codes and they're defined uh by
two uh
checkes called HX
and HZ and um the uh all important
property that they have to fulfill is
that uh uh H that time HX transpose has
to be Z two I will everything is done
over F2 so I will always kind of have
skip the um okay that's good um there's
an alternative description uh and this
is using p
graphs so let me draw this so here we
have um three
layers the middle
layer are our bits say end
this then we have uh one layer
above which are our Z
checks and one layer
below and these are our next
Che yeah and uh we connect uh a bit with
a check if this uh bit is is um
participa in the checks yeah so for
example this Z check acts on these two
pits okay and then um okay I won't draw
anymore any more edges but
uh importantly the incidence relation
between these nodes and these
notes uh is encoded in
the uh and similarly uh we have our X
checks and this will be uh the incid
okay and now um what we seen in John's
talk
um so this important condition yeah
which is necessary to Define uh CSS
code tells us that if I pick any
two uh any any pair of an X check and a
z check then their overlap has to be
even yeah so
we have like
this okay so this is just a a more
visual way of um talking about this but
it's it's just an equivalent
definition okay so now um let me give
you the
definition um the
family uh of CSS
codes
PPC where uh ldpc stands for low
density parity
check um if equivalently HX and
HZ uh are uh
Spar
agencies or equivalently if uh
uh the ten graph
uh is
f yeah meaning that uh the degree of
each note is bounded by some
con okay so that's the
definition let me uh also say a little
bit so everything has been quite
abstract so far so we talk about kind of
doing checks but uh I'm sure you
appreciate that um like computer is a
very physical device yeah so the the
quantum information is held in some qu
mechnical system so um how does it
actually work how can we kind of perform
these checks it's very simple in the
classical world we just kind of our code
word is just a a string of zeros and
ones right you can just look at them and
then kind of compute the parity but um
in a computer let's say our our cubits
are uh spins yeah they're like little
spins and um so we have to kind of work
a little bit harder to kind of I know
perform these parity checks so in
particular so measuring
check uh
involving
mbits involves uh what a physicist would
call
facilitating uh an mbody
interaction yeah so sticking with this
uh with this example so let's say our
our cubits are um spins or atoms yeah
then what an experimentalist would have
to do is he has to they have to um
orchestrate yeah kind of getting this
these these uh these um these items kind
close together make them interact yeah
and then put them put them apart and do
a measurement yeah and you can imagine
um that uh kind of facilitating and kind
of orchestrating such an interaction is
is quite involved yeah so people have to
kind work very very very hard in the lab
yeah to do this um so um I hope I can
kind of
um convey that uh in fact all reasonable
codes that we that we consider are ldpc
codes yeah we can't because we can't
facilitate arbitrary uh interactions
between between our our items or our
spins or whatever system we use
foration um yeah so virtually all um uh
codes we consider or families of codes
we consider are quantum LPC codes
however this not not a vacuous
definition yeah otherwise I would talk
about correction in this talk um because
there's a colloquial meaning to qpc so
let me give you the colloquial
meaning
um and this is um that these codes have
high
rate and large
distance
[Music]
and also usually there's like a notion
of giving up physical
locality and I will make this uh more
precise uh in in the next couple of
hours and um one thing I I want I want
to kind of say at this point is um these
two things actually go hand in hand yeah
um because it turns out that if we have
special constraints
uh then this implies constraints on code
parameters um so for example there's
there's several results let me just kind
of highlight one um so we know that um
uh if our uh code in some sense lives in
two Dimensions so for example we have
justor code which is a two dimensional
layout right uh and for such codes we
know that uh the number of encoded
cubits times the distance squared is
bounded by the number of so remember
every code comes with three parameters n
k and
D yeah and the number of cubits we have
the ones which are which are which into
is the number of logical cbits this is
degrees of freedom that we an and E is
the distance and if you remember from
John's talk uh for the um aor code this
number was two so just a constant and
this was uh on a lce this was L yeah and
the total number was two * l^ s yeah so
it just satisfies this Bond and it turns
out we can't do any
better if we stay in
2D um yeah this is a bond due to to
uh um okay so
[Music]
um now uh the reason why we would want
to uh um give up physical locality um is
because because of this reason yeah
because qpc Cod kind of promise that we
can we can do better than this yeah we
can kind of um get better Cod parameters
and
um there's other reasons to kind of look
into qpc codes so um one is um with what
an Krishna will will go into in his talk
um where a theorem du to Gman kind of
promises that we can perform for
tolerance much much more efficiently
using qpc codes um yeah and this is the
application in in con Computing but it
turns out um that uh qpc codes have
found various other applications so let
me just kind named two of them one is in
complexity Theory turns out because um
these structures that that people have
found in in the search for good copc
codes turned out to be useful for um
poonian complexity also for um classical
complexity theories so uh some more
Square bounds um and um even even
further mov from this uh turns out that
you can use the cical constructions in
Geometry so there are conjectures in
Geometry which have been proved using
the construction of
okay all right so uh This was um just
the introduction and a bit of
reminder oh yeah
please oh I will talk about this
tomorrow okay okay yeah put a pin in
that and then ask me again yes good any
other questions at this
point it's about theing interaction to
simulate any like G with there's some
Asis to this yeah so um there are ways
of kind of circumventing this um and I'm
not going to actually talk about this so
there's something called subsystem codes
where you kind of essentially do this
there also other kind of ways you can
use quantum codes but if you just I'm
just kind of talking if you naively want
to implement condom code and you want to
kind naely Implement these par checks
then um they better not be kind of too
complicated
but you have absolutely right there's
like way of kind of circumventing this
yes any other
questions okay not um yeah then let me
uh talk a bit about constructions of
QBC
okay and um well it turns out that um I
mean ldpc kind of comes from the from
the from classic coding Theory obviously
so we kind of we lazy we always put like
a Que in front of anything that the
classical people can come up with um and
LPC codes are just uh classical codes so
just kind of we ignore one of one of
these two uh codes yeah and then we just
have a classical code and LPC is just
defined in the same way so it just means
that the t is fast yeah and uh or ly we
just have one par check Matrix and this
has to be Spar um and um in the classic
world we actually we actually kind of
somewhat spoiled uh because it turns out
um so for classical LPC
codes uh we can just
pick check
Matrix H uh to be random in
spar
and then we are guaranteed uh that uh K
will be n
and will be yeah with
probility yeah so we don't have to work
very hard to get an asally optimal code
yeah um so why don't we just do the same
thing for for for LPC codes so let's
let's try this so
um uh try this for
Quantum way so
uh so we just pick let's say HX at
random doesn't matter whether it's X or
Z random is
FSE um and now as a reminder uh for CSS
we now have to kind of find the uh
HZ uh and we require
that
HX
hos has to be
zero okay can anybody kind of already
see like where we running into trouble
here so this equation essentially tells
us that um the checks of the Z code are
code words of the X
code
yeah but those we know are linear in
size right so so this Matrix can never
be Spar
yeah yeah
so
uh here and then St tells us H
that um yeah
so uh what do we do now uh and uh yeah
so this kind of I know kind of leads me
to into like several constructions of of
LPC codes that I'm going to discuss and
um I have a question why is parity a
necessity um so that was kind of U the
point I was making here so when we want
to implement the the code right we have
to perform these checks yeah and I can't
go into too many details of how we do
this but it turns out this is like very
very complicated for for the
experimentalists so I I would love to
just tell them just kind of take a
random code just do it um but then they
will come back to me and say like oh
it's it's hard and then I have to have
do the work um yeah so uh that's how it
is so some other structure might also
help right instead of yeah exactly so so
um so we do need to kind of introduce
more structure um and in fact um kind
of yeah so so I mean the way to kind of
getting good qpc codes was essentially
first they were like random
constructions and then it turned out
that you can actually der randomize but
we can of get that
um any more
questions uh what if you try random but
require x z to be
SP um so it's a bit a question like how
would how would you kind of I Know
sample this right because you would have
to kind of constrain how you sample HX
in the first place and that's kind of
the question right like it's kind
unclear how you set up this Ensemble um
I mean it's it's it's a good idea and I
think I'm pretty sure lots of people
have tried um but turned out that that
wasn't way of doing
it um I feel like there is a subtle
difference between how ldpc code is used
in the classical sense and this
typically in the classical sense you
have your end bits and you have some
errors in the end bits what you get to
observe are exactly these erroneous ends
right but here you get to observe some
syndromes of the erroneous B
yeah in I mean in classical information
Theory I think this is called like the
syndrome Source coding problem which is
very closely related to the error
correction problem but there are some
subtle differences between the the two
right any this
play oh um yeah so I mean that's kind
Place into the decoding problem that uh
I might kind of touch up on a little bit
later but actually Annie will talk about
in more detail um so maybe looking in
that uh but it's a very good question
and actually this is like why we're here
right because we we I think like the
decoding problem for qpc CES just kind
of say that up front I think it's it's
somewhat open so we don't actually know
how to decode them in in a good way so I
hope I hope like classical people can
really help with this um I mean even
more than the decoding problem is this
truly a error correction problem or is
this something that's closely related to
an error correction problem but slightly
a different problem I'm not sure to
answer this question uh I mean I put
[Music]
um well maybe maybe the classical
problem has closed to like code word
stabilized codes so if I think of I
think of a general class correction code
maybe I'm more likely think of it as
code word
stabilized but for us Quantum side we
almost always work with linear codes yes
yes yes which I think is what this oh
okay oh I see okay um
yes okay yeah
um okay I still know like what what the
answer would be that you're looking for
but maybe we can have chat offline and
then um okay so um all right so we kind
of talked a little bit about like random
constructions and and and why it's hard
uh so in fact turns out that um a lot of
the initial construction of QC codes
have been done geometrically and in fact
also including uh the ones which which
held the distance bound record for like
almost 20 years yeah um but let me start
again with our uh uh nice Tory code and
I'm I'm happy that John hyped you up uh
Tory code
uh um and I would have explain it um as
a holog
c
code and just to remind you again so we
have some Square
letters on tus so we have um these two
sides identified and these two sides
identified and we have our
checks so we have
our check Associated uh um to the
vertices and we have our cubits living
on the edges I'm not going to bother to
kind of draw little points for the
cubits just assume that there's an a
cubit Associated to every Edge and then
we do our our ex par check measurement
here and then we have our uhet or I will
call them
faces um yeah
yeah now um I can kind of again kind of
rewrite it turns out the only thing
which kind of uh is important here is
like the incidence relationship right
like which Edge belongs to which vertex
and which Edge belongs to which pH so I
can I can write this
abstractly uh as a partially ordered
set where I put my faces here and I put
the
not each
face uh and I have my edges
here and I put
notes each
edge
here
um yeah but now note that oh yeah and
they they're connected if let's say like
this pH here is this
one right has connected to four edges
yeah which are the ones which go around
here and maybe that's a Vertex here
which is this one and it's connected to
uh let's see these two right which are
the ones which are shared in this face
in this vertex and then other
ones um yeah but now you see this this
this PO set yeah this incidence
relationship between faces edges and
vertices is exactly the tag right
um and um more importantly there is also
something that John told you that if you
if you take any any vertex and any face
they will always either overlap on zero
edges or they will overlap on two
edges and turns out um this this is a a
general property of um of so-called um
Regular uh CH uh C complexes so
poets
uh
regular C
complexes contain
graphs of C
okay so I didn't Define what a cell
complex is just imagine I have any uh
topological space and I just subdivided
into pieces so I subdivide it into into
uh into let's say it's two dimensional I
subdivide it into any type of of uh uh
edes yeah which are then connect via
edges and then I
have um so let me give you addition
example
so um additional
and that's the high dimensional cousin
of the Tor code which is the 3D T
code yeah so I take uh um a 3D
letters or
3DX yeah and imagine I identify this
side with this side and this side with
this side and the front with the with
the back and I subdivide this into into
uh cubes
everywhere I can also write down this uh
this incidence relationship between
let's say
all all the cubes
right then I have all the square
faes I have my
edges and I have my
VES
yeah and um each uh let's say each face
is incident
to
four edges right and each uh Edge is
incident to two vertices and so on
okay so now um turns out uh I can just
kind of use this and just take let's
say uh
this sub
here and I'm guaranteed that this will
Define a uh a valid CSS code yeah so I
can identify my edges again with with
cubits and I have my faces as Z checks
and my vertices as X checks yeah and
this will Define a valid code so what is
this code
um so uh let's
say we have uh
and l l l yeah then I hope you can
believe me that uh the number of edges
in here will scale as as
what how many how many how many edges
will be there in
this cubed
um however and John already already told
the um The Logical operator kind of
associated here uh will be um a
non-contractible
loop so how long is this non conductible
Loop in this
L it's still L yeah exactly so our
distance is just L yeah but this means
that our distance is just third root uh
of M right so we made a code but this
code is actually worse yeah it's it's
less efficient so um um yeah so this is
not the way the way to go um however um
using a much more complicated
construction it was shown in uh O2 by
Freedman Maya and
L
uh yeah like um like five years after
after K that we can
construct a fault different from the 3D
taus and different from the 2D taus such
that the
distance um is fourth
root of log n * sare of n
yeah so we we beat the the Tor codes by
a fourth root of a log yeah and just for
fun let me let me explain to you how
this construction works so um let me
just use my hands so we take a uh a
hyperbolic re surf so a surface with
negative curvature and we look at a
translation in the surface yeah and the
translation is of length uh root of a
log of the area of the surface we then
kind of Trace out this translation and
then glue it back together we get a 3D
manold then we take another controlled
product in a fourth Direction so we get
a 4D manold yeah and this will have uh
this property yeah so we have to work
very very hard this is you don't have to
understand this but I justed it as a bit
um to kind of show you that you have to
have to work very very hard to beat the
very very simple trusty Tor code yeah
okay um all right so questions I'm sure
there's
questions yes please so if you were to
implement something like that example on
physical or like would you get like very
non loal interaction yes yes yes so um
exactly so um maybe let me let me make a
very general comment so um these
geometric constructions they don't
assume that you have to kind of lay out
your cubits in this like four
dimensional hyperbolic whatever space
it's just to kind of get get this graph
yeah that's what we want and we want to
kind of I know then kind of prove these
properties but the nice thing is
geometry is kind of like a like a tool
because now we can use geometry to kind
of kind of prove these things right I
mean when we when we proved the distance
of the of the Tory code we didn't even
have to think right we just kind of said
oh yeah it's
Loop in an L lce obviously it's l right
um and kind of similarly we can use very
sophisticated tools from differential
geometry to kind of prove these things
um so it's kind of like a just very nice
um like rdge to kind of I know get get a
handle on on these like very complicated
codes um but sorry yeah I had a question
ear about you also wrote about like k s
has to be like like is that like
strictly true for when you have like
local checks or yes yes yes so so you
assume that the essentially what you can
assume is essentially that this um that
we can kind of lay out this uh this
graph more more or less planer uh and um
and then you can kind of yeah prove
prove this bound okay and there's other
bounds which kind of also hold in higher
dimensions and so on uh I mean I should
also say this only holds in ucan space
this actually kind breaks if you assume
that you're underlying space is curved
um but um and then there's other bonds
you can prove but yeah let me
just yeah yes please so you took faces
Edge vertices to Define your tner graph
you have also gotten something
interesting if you had done like cubes
faes edges instead I can do that exactly
yeah so I can just kind of shift this up
exactly the funny thing is about the the
cubic lce it's selfdual yeah so kind of
flipping this this uh this graph doesn't
actually change anything that's special
the the number of dimensions
that's special to the number of
dimensions and also to the um to the to
the cubic subdivision of a torus there's
other there's other codes um where it
would make a difference
um uh yeah there's other letteres you
can kind of you can of tile the taus and
then then it does make a difference um
but I mean you never you never beat this
yeah this is kind of like a kind of
global geometric property yeah so the
subdivision won't really help you
subdivision just tells you what the
degree of the checks is not so much like
the global
properties do we care about the rate as
much as the distance uh yeah I didn't so
I don't really talk much about the rate
here um I will get back to that uh so I
will talk about rate when we talk about
product constructions um the thing is we
can get high rate also with geometric
constructions
um and I tempted to talk about like let
me let me not talk about it maybe I'll
talk about it tomorrow as like a extra
tweet um but yeah let me just kind of
mute
that okay any other any other questions
yes for the hardness of random
construction um where did you exactly
use the fact that X is random did you
just use oh I used it because um X Is
Random so I know this so actually holds
for any x with a good distance
not oh yeah yeah sure I mean because
just because of this right because uh
like the the checks have to be code
words of this and if this is a good code
bad thing turns out I see so it's
telling you that X canot can yeah yeah
that's a weird thing right like it has
to be it has to be we want the um um
needs to be some kind of like weird Gap
right it's because we want the the the
checks to be sparse right so there there
should be like lots of lots of code
Words which we use as checks which are
very very small but then the actual
information uh is contained in the ones
which are very very large yeah and this
like a weird thing somehow we have to
kind of get a code which has kind of
like a weird Gap in some sense uh in
its in its code words um
yeah that's kind of the difficulty yeah
and any more
questions
okay um let me just kind of draw like
one
uh one little reminder and then I'm kind
of done with the geometric
constructions
um so the
um
is um
so
geometric
um so we start with some uh
manys which is
subid into
vertices
edges and so
on um let me just kind of throw like a
picture so it doesn't have to be a two
Dimension surface but kind of like this
now we uh kind of have our
cubits um uniformly kind of
living in this
space um then the uh number of cubits n
scales with the
volume of the m
uh and
uh
K it's just the uh
number
ofra Loops for the high dimension
versions non
contractable because it can
Beal
guys John already said
uh the
distance is
uh
smallest
uh Mo or could
beere okay um all right um okay that's
all I had to say about um about
geometric constructions uh so far
um how am I doing with time okay I have
like 20
minutes okay any any questions regarding
uh Geet
constructions this is just for the
choice versus Ed just faces I guess uh
no so I kind of put Loops in parenthesis
um I will kind of explain tomorrow what
I actually mean by this I mean like
non-c contractable sub manys yeah so in
2D the only only sub I can have here is
just a one dimensional one in higher
Dimensions I can have something which is
I can have like a surface which is more
compatible right um that's why I kind
of more questions oh when you say
proportional is there global conern or
some can it be oh that that can that can
depend on like how I subdivide my manold
and like a bunch of other details um but
um
yeah
okay so now uh I want to talk about
um the more
um uh successful
approach in in increasing the the
distance um and these are uh produ
constructions
and um for this uh let me um consider uh
The Humble repetition code so uh what
does the tenagra of a repetition code
look
like so I can out exactly so I have pair
W checks on my
bits um
this
one like this right so this is a 313
repetition code right where these are my
par checks acting on my bits and the
only code words I can have are 0 or one
one1 okay now let me do my Trick In
Reverse so earlier I said I can take um
some solidation of manifold and kind of
turn this into a ten graph let me do
this in Reverse so let me just
Proclaim that these are now
vertices these are
edges then uh the space I
get
is this grop right because uh yeah these
are now my my
checks right ales and then I have an
edge which are my bits and each bit is
checked by two
checks okay and again code words are
uh um just assigning 00 Z or 11 one to
all the
edges um
okay now the thing I want to convey is
um in some sense uh a classical code is
a one dimensional object yeah because we
have these two layers we have vertices
and we have edges but we have nothing
higher yeah which we need to Define our
CSS construction yeah
so the the the thought is how do I take
something which is classical like
onedimensional and turn it into
something which is higher dimensional
yeah which is quantum yeah so any any
suggestion how I take this and turn it
into something High
dimensional count faces sorry faces or
something like that of a Gra yeah so so
what I want to do is I want to take um
so maybe you have seen that if I take
two
Loops I take the
product what do I
get
Theus
exactly and um all right so uh what are
what are the um and it's not any any so
if I if I assume that I have aimation
here I get a simulation here
so let me first kind of write down what
are my
faces so these will be products between
two edges so one edge here and one edge
here yeah this will always give me a
square face right I take of two edges
and a square face now the edges in here
are products
between uh an edge and the
vertex
or
vertex and an
edge
yeah product between two
veres is that kind of intuitively clear
like this is literally just like like
topologically what it is um and
um uh yeah and we can Define inces
between
between between this and
this and we get uh yeah we use this to
Define our code so we get our our HZ and
our HX and what we got was exactly the T
code yeah so this my magic trick so I I
took a repetition code I took two
repetition codes and I defined the Tory
code from these two repetition codes
yeah the Tory code in some sense is like
the quantum version of the repetition
code
okay
um all
right any
questions um
okay
question question yeah if you know a
decoder for the classical Cod you also
know decoder for the resting very good
question um I wish so uh I think people
people are thinking about this but I
think there's also like no like fully
satisfactory answer and it's also
something we could maybe discuss in the
course of this program it's actually one
of the questions I had in mind because
it's not it's not immediately
clear um yeah how you would kind of
implement um you can't just kind of
decode each factor
individually um you could kind of
imagine you can just kind project down
your error right in each factor and then
decode on each factor and then kind of
lift back but this naive approach
doesn't really doesn't really work so
well you have lose distance so you have
to do something a little bit more clever
but I don't know I'm not clever enough
so maybe somebody
else that's a very good
question
any other
questions
okay
um
so and then I'm kind of closer
toite
okay um so um let me kind of rephrase or
kind of give a a different symbol to
this incidence relationship um so let me
call the incidence between faces and
edges let me call that uh D2 and let me
call this D one yeah just a little T of
notation and I always kind of mean this
when I kind of talk about um incid
matri so the question is like what is
what does the
incidence
uh between
edes
and
and I
can call this one of the uh the
product it turns out that if I if I have
write this up um then I get con product
between identity
Matrix
times uh
one on the input VOR let say it's called
it's called the C yeah it's called
the and I get uh the incidence incident
Matrix or the par Matrix of and
then there one
C okay and um yeah you can easily kind
of convince yourself of this just by
kind of checking that uh uh let's say
this Edge yeah which is a vertical Edge
is incident to exactly two uh vertices
which are the products between like two
vertices here so I can fix a Vertex here
then I have two vertices here and here
yeah and this is exactly the instance
relationship from my initial DC and I
don't anything on
the exactly encoded in this this
Matrix okay
um so call this horizontal
okay uh and now the last
thing I want to talk about um is
essentially the um uh the way uh the um
the code words in the product structure
relate to the code words in the input
factors and this is uh called the K
theorem
um it essentially tells us that um the
code
words uh of the factor
codes uh
C
uh uh
lift
words uh
in
uh the product
Cod okay so um let me just kind dra it
here uh
thisle
so um
um let's say we draw our our code right
here which is non trial so let's say
111 highlight edges one
here now it turns out that if I take
this code word yeah then this lifts into
a code word in the T code yeah which is
exactly this cont here yeah and you can
see where where this happens uh because
if I just take zero here and I take one
here yeah and I kind of plck this into
my par check Matrix yeah I'm only
checked by uh by the initial parity
check Matrix of the input code and
nothing happens on the other on the
other
side
okay um yeah and similarly on uh on this
one so if I
take right
here on the horizontal
edges then
I can lift this into a code word here
yeah and these are my two uh uh code
words um that I have in my my my to code
these are the two Contra Loops that I
have in my to
Cod
okay any
questions
so you can hear code as kind of product
of repetition codes um but you can also
view the 9 short code as a kind of I
don't know like contamination or some
kind of you
know product of repetition code so could
you you say elaborate a bit more about
like you know what's what's different
about then like we also heard about CSS
constructions which are
also I guess you know principle
repetition so like what's are we talking
about the CSS construction or we talking
no no this all I'm talking about is CSS
right because every time I have I have
two par check matrices right uh um
yeah faces right so everything I talk
about is CSS um you
mentioned be
exactly yeah yeah exactly exactly and
and you mentioned um I mean I I see
where you come from that the short code
is uh you take it's also like in some
sense like a repetition version uh like
qu but there the construction is a
little bit different right like there
was
no you as you said like construction
yeah rather than like a like a GE
[Music]
construction
um
okay any more yes pleas can you repeat
what a punchline here of this the so you
have the Cod for C Cod for what the
claim about the Cod
fore uh okay let me let me get to the
punch line uh and the punch line
um
uh
um this um so they had the more um comor
view uh and they called this
Construction
I
um and um okay so the the okay so the
idea is essentially I took the
repetition code here right but nothing
stops me from taking any other classical
code right I can take any any classical
code I Define this product I get some
really strange like of uh product
structure but it doesn't matter yeah the
whole the whole construction goes
through yeah I still get a valid CSS
code yeah
um so um what uh what they observed is
if if I put in I already said I know we
know how to get uh Tess codes um
so no how to
construct
um with
uh
a m and
n right and now I plug this in into this
construction then what what do I get so
first of all uh um I get that uh my K so
in uh my k
so first of my
n
um so my
n just to the squ
right if I take if I take like a 3X3
repetition code repetition code I get by
9 by n uh
taus my uh
uh my
K will be k squ this is exactly the
statement of the K theorem yeah that I
can take any any Cod word of each
individual factor I can lift it so I get
k s k squar
uh Loops in this
strcture just as for the for the T code
uh because of the con theum or not quite
because of the con theum um I also know
that uh an upper bound on on the
distance that I can have right because I
can take any uh code word here kind of
lifted into here but this thing is of
size uh square root like of of uh Square
size yeah and this is of linear size
yeah so the the distance can only be
square root in the in the product
structure yeah exactly as it is here
yeah so the
distance at the most uh will be uh will
be square Ro of N and what proved it's
it can be exactly n yeah
so exactly
this and um yeah let me kind of stop
here because uh I will kind of go into a
little bit of the right uh no n whoops
square root yeah yeah
thank so we can we can get something
which has the same distance as as a t
code but much better encoding rate
yeah because this is
again
um okay and um I will maybe tomorrow
kind of go into a little bit of like why
this is and again kind of um then
develop uh the formalism that makes
this this perspective but I didn't
actually talk abouty so maybe talk about
this little tomorrow um yeah but I'm to
take any
questions so can does it say say um you
can go from the
product uh CSS code to the original
classical code because without that you
can't um argue the distance oh yeah yeah
so so it only giv an upper bound on the
distance MH yeah it doesn't give you a
lower bon in lower Bones is like much
harder yeah so so um yeah I kind get
into this
tomorrow yeah from the product
construction how understand the Quantum
Code
canate um so the degeneracy just comes
from this high dimensionality property
right so um this just kind of comes from
the fact that you have uh like these two
codes kind of interacting right and one
being uh like one set of checks being
code words of the of the other code
that's where the dety comes
from Andy doesn't exist in the classical
case right because you can just kind of
pick your par checks to be
independent yeah but but you you are
forced to have linear dependencies once
you talk
about
objects any more
questions um I mean I guess you could
play a similar game here where you go to
higher Dimension but is it similar like
maybe instead of starting with like two
Loops I start with like two man like two
sphs or yeah I could also iterate this
right like I mean like the the 3D Tory
code I showed you I can just take three
loops and I get exactly that yeah is it
the same sort of phenomenon that you
starting with one
Dimensions the paramet um actually good
codes you can kind of think of as
starting with two two dimensional spaces
but then two two dimensional spaces with
like a really strange way of doing doing
checks like they're not um yeah let me
get into this tomorrow yeah so it's
something called uh homology with t
coefficient
I have a really n question you using n
cubits in the simplest code n cubits to
en one
cubit the probability of error when you
have n cubits it's higher because of
your N9 cubits oh yeah yeah really help
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah so that's a very
good question actually so so um yeah
yeah so let me rephrase your question so
the issue is if we assume let's say we
have some some error model right like we
just have like independent bit flips on
all all cubits yeah then like a linear
number of of cubits will undergo an
error right um but it turns out that um
even though uh your distance is lower uh
you can still show that you can correct
back uh reliability in a reliable way
and I think an will kind talk about this
more this is kind of like called the
threshold phenomenon um where um for
example like even even for the Tory code
right um uh the Tory code only has like
square root n distance right but the
expected number of of Errors is of order
n right because like each individually
it's like P * n yeah um but it turns out
that um uh if you make your uh um your T
code larger and larger yeah there's like
um some sort of like percolation
transition that happens yeah and below
this percolation transitions we can we
can arbitrarily uh um like the
probability of incorrect decoding goes
to zero exponentially yeah this a very
good question but I'm not going to talk
about this but yeah an will kind of
cover this in
his please what you said true if a
distance is any like small power of n
like n to like point one or
whatever like there be a finite ER pral
as long as distance is oh yeah even even
so we can so this a result by uh uh u f
and and others um that actually it
suffices to just have logarithmic
distance as long as distance is
scaling
fter and in fact there are I mean so I
didn't so kind goes back to your earli
question so um you can Define um codes
with have logarithmic distance and
linear linear rate and actually they
perform quite well so these are called
hyperbolic codes you just have teic Min
folds you to
their the definition of the CSS Cally
and they actually perform quite well
even though the distance is only
logarithmic
yeah what do you mean by
per uh oh yeah just just kind of uh if
you just kind kind of look at um you
just kind of have some toy error model
and you just do numerical simulations
and then you kind compare let straight
up compare uh
uh
result in the interest of time we can
take uh further questions offline so
let's
[Applause]
uh so just a few quick announcements